resident evil was one of my first
playstation games and as much as i hate
to admit it 11 year old me was too
scared to play it alone it was the
silence of the trap-related
monster-infested spencer mansion for one
that racked my brain wow
what a mansion the auditory void and
infrequent threats provided a false
sense of tranquility but in the back of
my mind i knew that i was walking
headlong into danger i felt at odds with
my capable and confident avatar and i
was always far more tense and nervous
than the brave jill or chris ever were
there was also the matter of the fixed
cameras you couldn't see what was around
the corner until you took the plunge and
sometimes you'd be standing nose to
gaping maw with a bloodthirsty vomiting
zombie there are always people ready to
criticize resident evil's fixed camera
as a crutch used by the developers to
get around the limitations of the
consoles at the time but the restricted
line of sight made the game scarier than
it would have been otherwise
you have to wonder did the dev team plan
from the start to limit your view and
only then opt for pre-rendered
backgrounds or was it the other way
around
either way the end result works and
while some people call it archaic i have
a fondness for fixed camera systems
because of how well it was utilized in
resident evil
when the game was ultimately remade for
gamecube in 2002 i was cognizant enough
to play scary games without buying into
the virtual fear tactics and was ready
to give spencer manchin another look
capcom stuck with the fixed camera
system which preserved the feel of the
original version and once again allowed
the developers to devote a hefty amount
of system resources to 3d models and
lighting effects with the increased
power of expression at his fingertips
the dev team crafted what i believe to
be the best looking game for the
gamecube uh this is one of the best
looking games on the gamecube
and i
love it the character models were
astounding for a console of its time and
nondescript scenes from the 32-bit
version were updated with experimental
camera angles and thoughtful
applications of light and darkness
seeing your shadow inch down the wall of
a corridor towards the shadows of
objects or zombies that lie ahead was a
subtle yet powerful way to encapsulate
the suspense you were experiencing in a
visual form you couldn't see what was
ahead but you were being fed information
that would let your imagination run wild
now capcom's reviving the gamecube
remake in hd for pc and modern consoles
for released in 2015 and while many hd
ports are simply the same game rendered
at a higher resolution capcom's updating
and creating new in-game assets that
based on the impressive demo i saw will
stand up to the test of hd displays
while some things such as the opening
cutscene components were preserved and
are easily updated a lot of assets are
being remade from scratch though the
version i played was still a work in
progress it already looks great despite
a few objects that give away the game's
standard definition roots though capcom
noted that these particular assets are
in the process of being updated
capcom is also adding a widescreen mode
to the gate it uses a pan and scan
system to create a wide screen frame
from within the original 4x3 window
which is odd at first to prevent certain
elements from being cut out from the
scene they've added a slight swing
motion to the camera however i got used
to it after a few minutes and it wasn't
distracting in the end for anyone who
feels at odds with the camera's motion
there is an option to enable the
original 4x3 presentation there's the
misconception that capcom is making an
hd remake of an hd remake but let's put
that to rest the gamecube didn't output
video at hd resolutions it's been a
while since i played the original remake
or the port that landed on the wii for
that matter so with the fog of time and
resident evil's fresh coat of paint the
early playstation 4 version i played
felt new all over again look out it's a
monster obviously only some of it's new
but i don't care the hour i played was
an absolute tease and i can't wait to
explore the depths of spencer mansion
and hd next year
no don't go